we have Space Camp ranked most prepared
for a zombie apocalypse hope you like
Canyon we got a grand one oh we have the
most dog owners most professional sports
teams nothing but net
we've got disproportionately more
gluten-free stuff as compared to the
national average an old-timey nickname
for us is the nut makers home to the
pumpkin Chunkin world championship this
thing where they use a bunch of devices
to throw pumpkins second largest ocean
coastline after Alaska we're number one
in barbecue state where you're least
likely to collide with a deer we produce
72 types of precious and semi-precious
stones deep-dish pizza the Indianapolis
Motor Speedway is the world's largest
spectator sporting facility we've got
the highest population of pigs
what are those pigs home to one of the
two largest balls of twine where's the
other one we have the longest cave
system whoa you've got the most single
people we've got the oldest population
the state sport is jousting holder the
top three most Irish towns : Michigan is
the self-proclaimed magic capital of the
world
we got the most golfers per capita we
get the most sleep per night on average
tied with Alabama aah
birthplace of Mark Twain and where most
of his famous stories took place
residents view it as the best place to
live
tied with Alaska we got the most homes
with indoor plumbing
do you like what you see prostitution is
legal in parts of Nevada the first free
public library was founded here in 1833
first state to ratify the Bill of Rights
we have the highest population of
Hispanic people birthplace to the most
astronauts first public university oh
thank you I did it
we got the largest penises we're the
most likely to mother in curse Oh
has a musical written about it I've
never seen it it looks great though
Portland Oregon has the most strip clubs
per capita we're home to Gettysburg
Independence Hall Liberty Bell and
Valley Forge National Park more Rhode
Islanders over the age of 12 smoked
marijuana monthly than any other state
where the most polite state thank you
very much cows outnumber people over
four to one home of Jack Daniels the
best-selling American whiskey in the
world Texas has the most deaths from
hands fists and feet we're number one in
volunteerism I'm not even getting paid
for this we've got the most craft
breweries per capita we got the most
vanity license plates per capita we're
the least likely took gosh-darn curse
home of the first Mother's Day
celebration happy Mother's Day
cheese ninety two point seven percent of
the population is Caucasian